is there life elsewhere in the universe
anyone who has pondered the immensity of
the cosmos as probably wondered at some
time or another whether life exists
beyond our planet one of the most
interesting and exciting questions that
people have been asking for millennia is
are we alone you know even as a child I
stared up at the night sky saw all those
stars and couldn't imagine that some of
them didn't have planets with people on
them who were looking back at me
wondering the same thing we are now at
the point where we can scientifically
answer that question the search for life
beyond Earth has been buoyed by recent
discoveries made by NASA's Kepler
telescope it's looking for planets
outside our solar system known as
exoplanets Kepler measures the
brightness of distant stars and tracks
as stars dimming when a planet passes in
front up until 1995 exoplanets were
purely theoretical but scientists have
since identified thousands of them
you know just twenty years ago we didn't
know of any planets beyond our solar
system and now here we are we know that
there's pretty much a planet for every
star and then we know about one out of
every five of those planets could Harbor
life that's such a profound difference
in one generations worth of work in our
understanding of the cosmos it blows me
away every time I think about it and it
blows me away every time I go out at
night because I can count
I can literally go and not just count
stars I can now count planets but one
thing that has been very important is
one of the real growth points of
astronomy at the moment is the
realization that most stars are orbited
by retinues of planets just as the Sun
is orbited by the earth and the other
familiar planets and
that many of those planets are rather
like the young earth there are probably
within our Milky Way galaxy billions of
planets well like the earth and of
course many people would guess that
there is life on them that we can't be
so sure about that nor what life is like
in July NASA scientists announced the
discovery of one of their most exciting
exoplanets yet
kepler-452b located some fourteen
thousand light-years away the planet is
in the habitable zone which means it's
the right distance from its own Sun and
also the right size to potentially be
earth-like so so kepler 452b
is one of the most habitable planets or
one of the most potentially habitable
planets that we've ever found of the
things that were able to measure about
this planet there's a lot of it that
seems much like what we experience here
on our own home planet and that's what's
that's what's got a lot of the
scientific communities so excited there
is a limit to how much we can learn
about kepler-452b because of its
distance NASA is launching the James
Webb telescope in 2018 to find
earth-like planets closer to home so
they can study their atmospheres for bio
signatures that would indicate the
presence of life but there's another way
to learn more about distant planets
beyond what the Kepler telescope can
tell us and that is to look for signs of
intelligent life Frank Drake has been
listening out for signals of intelligent
life elsewhere in the universe for over
50 years
mr. Drake came up with something called
the Drake Equation which is a
mathematical formula that estimates how
many advanced civilizations capable of
transmitting signals might exist in the
universe he co-founded the SETI
Institute the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence scientists
at the SETI Institute have been
searching for intelligent life for the
past few decades
how does SETI search well we look at our
own technology and determine which one
of our technologies is detectable across
the distances which separate the stars
what we can detect is our radio signals
our television broadcasts of which of
course there are thousands our radar
transmissions which are even easier to
detect and so we search for those and so
just recently to the radio search we
have added a light search SETI
researchers have not come across any
signals yet but they say this is to be
expected so in our galaxy a couple
hundred billion stars we've looked
carefully it may be a couple of thousand
stars right that means we've looked at
one millionth of the star systems in our
galaxy carefully 1 million so you know
that's like I'm into the ocean taking a
glass of water and saying now you see
any sharks in there Bob well I don't
well I guess there are no sharks in the
ocean well it'd be a little premature
right all that means is your sample size
isn't big enough and that would be very
discouraging if it weren't to the fact
that the technology keeps getting faster
so there's hope SETI's efforts recently
got a huge boost with a launch of
breakthrough listen overseen by Martin
Rees Stephen Hawking and Frank Drake and
funded by Silicon Valley entrepreneur
Yuri Milner the project will greatly
expand the organization's capacity to
search and sift through data but
scientists aren't only interested in
discovering life forms light-years away
of course the only places we can
directly look for life apart from earth
are on the planets and moons of our
solar system and there has been talk
about couldn't be some kind of life on
Mars could there be something on comets
could there be something under the
frozen ice on Europa one of Jupiter's
moons or Enceladus one of Saturn's moons
and it's possible that people find life
no one expects any very complex life in
those places but even evidence a simple
life would be more at first glance our
solar system seems like a rather
unlikely place to find life beyond Earth
but the reason scientists think it is
plausible is because of the discovery of
a group of organisms called
extremophiles they live on earth
so extremophiles are a group of
organisms that we've discovered that
live in what we consider extreme
environments and so we have found
organisms that live at temperatures that
exceed boiling water at pH is the same
lower lower than battery acid scientists
are looking at the moons of Jupiter and
Saturn as well as our nearest neighbor
Mars
and so what we're looking for is
something that might with microscope
might look like life life needs water so
we've been very interested in water
worlds so what the Curiosity rover doing
is doing now is going around Gale Crater
and investigating ancient riverbeds and
features that indicate and chemistry
that indicate that there was water
present you look at Jupiter it's a big
gas ball you figure it probably no life
there and that's probably true but
Jupiter has I don't think like close to
70 moons that we know about and several
of them are very large you know the size
of our own moon maybe even a little bit
bigger at least three of them are
thought to have underneath their
surfaces and the surface might just be
ice or rock but underneath maybe 10
miles down maybe a hundred miles down
they might have liquid oceans hidden
dark inky dark oceans down there with
with liquid water that's been sitting
there for four billion years so after
that length of time there might be
something that's cooked up in there the
hope is that if we find further life in
our solar system on places like Mars we
will improve our understanding of how
easily it might have started elsewhere
but there is another way to answer this
question determining how it started on
earth
so until we understand how life began we
don't know how likely it is or how
unique the pathway was that led to life
on earth one man who is trying to come
up with an answer to this question it's
Jack szostak in his lab at Harvard
University he's trying to determine how
easy it is to create life by making it
himself so we work on the origin of life
we are trying to do simple experiments
in the lab that will give us some clues
as to how life got started on the early
earth our approaches to work with the
chemicals that we think were involved
and try to see how they could assemble
into a simple kind of self modern cells
are intricate nano scale factories
stuffed with thousands of different
chemicals each taking part in a
complicated and messy web of reactions
long strands of DNA and codicils genetic
information shorter strands of RNA carry
that information around the cell telling
it how to manufacture the proteins that
run the chemical reactions it requires
to live it seems unlikely that these
systems all evolved at the same time at
the Shostak lab they're focused on two
experiments one to work out how
primitive cell membranes could grow and
divide into daughter cells and the other
on RNA replication so we hope to be able
to recreate the conditions in lab that
allowed life to come about in the first
place on the earlier
and a big part of that is learning how
to make RNA that can undergo spontaneous
self-replication without the need for
modern-day enzymes dr. Shah stack and
his team have already created a
protocell from a blob of lipids which
contains RNA the sticking point at the
moment is working out how to make RNA
they can copy itself without relying on
a helping hand from RNA enzymes the
ultimate goal this is to create from
chemicals a simple living system where
we can see Darwinian evolution operating
the emergence of new functions so in a
sense it's it would be a reconstitution
of the beginnings of biology in a lab
setting one of the things they hope to
learn from that of course is how life
might have started on the early Earth if
it is a difficult process reliant upon
various bits of luck or circumstance
then it is possible that we are a cosmic
fluke one that isn't going to be
repeated elsewhere but if experiments
like dr. Shah Stax show that life
emerges easily then the odds of life
appearing elsewhere in the universe look
more likely perhaps one day when we're
looking into the night sky we'll finally
know the answer to the question are we
alone
you